[Musique]
c'est difficile parce que maintenant nous devons
expliquer à la patiente quel est le délai
et souvent nous savons qu'il y a
des appels en attente
donc c'est difficile pour nous car
nous répondons toujours immédiatement
[Musique]
quand elle a appelé au départ elle
voulait juste  quelqu'un pour venir la voir
et nous avons donc une sœur des signes vitaux et
elle a décidé de ne pas aller à l'hôpital
elle était là hier elle a attendu
dehors pendant environ quatre heures
et ils ne pouvaient pas l'aider car il
n'y avait pas d'appât disponible pour elle
et  elle ne veut pas que la même situation se
reproduise maintenant
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que nous pourrions le supporter pendant
encore trois mois
vous savez et nous avons travaillé très dur pour
que notre personnel ait déjà
pris 30 coups et  nous sommes maintenant en train de
revenir à la normale
cela a été stressant pour le personnel c'est
un énorme
problème psychologique à gérer pendant trois mois vous
savez que vous avez affaire à des personnes positives
au quotidien et vous devez y aller
la maison à vos familles
[Musique]
un